so I'm gonna introduce them the paper of
today that is basically addressing
whether surgical masks can prevent viral
spread so they are in Japan is already
introduced introduce me but for whoever
was not paying attention
my name is Francisca so I come from
Santiago Chile so this is our very small
and like its peak but a narrow country
in the tip of South America from here
and you can see here this is a picture
of one of the national parks and over
there so we have plenty of volcanoes
lakes and greenery it's really nice so
whenever there are flies to go there
again you can take a beautiful vacation
down there if you have the time and the
money so I normally I came so I came
here to New York to study to do my PhD
at the Rockefeller University and I
normally and I work specialize in
neuroscience so my date today is working
with mice and basically start eating
brains and understanding how the neurons
in their brains work so neurons are the
cells that like inside the brain that
execute all these amazing functions that
led to our behavior and they and of
every animal so normally what I do is I
have a microscope and I try to look at
the neurons and understand what is it
that they are doing they're making the
animal think move and make a decision
but today we're not gonna talk about
that we're gonna talk about what it's
important now which curve which is copy
19 on related topics so just to be clear
I'm not about urology's I'm not an
immunologist I'm not an expert in any
means I'm just a scientist who happen to
be able to read papers and communicate a
little bit of this information to
everyone everyone so to start with
normally so what do we mean by
scientific literature
normally when by something when I do my
research I have to then I have to
find something like I haven't hypotheses
that I'm going to sort address and then
with a set of experiments trying to
answer and reach a conclusion and once I
do that I'm gonna publish these into a
scientific journal so I'm gonna write it
down I'm gonna be very specific about
the topic the methods and all the
techniques that I'm using and report all
my data and this is the proper way to do
it but the problem is that it is very
specific it has a lot of difficult words
that normally this is the kind of
literature that only goes to my peers
fellow scientists and it doesn't go to
regular people okay and this is so
normally scientific literature you can
find it in two forms the most common one
that we all rely on is the ones that
experie you this means that once I have
my mind paper basically written I send
into a journal that is gonna send it to
three or four different scientists who
work in the field but I'm not related to
my work they're gonna read it goes read
in an analytical with an analytical
perspective and then I basically make
sure that everything I'm doing is is
correct
everything I'm showing makes sense and
it's basically follow the gold standards
to ensure that it's a date
it has quality and rigor and you are not
falsifying any data but also you can I
can one other thing that I can do with
mine my research it to upload it to the
web to specific a websites and have a
preprint version which is basically the
same version that I send the peer-review
reputed reviewers but this one has not
been peer reviewed yet so these people
have not correct
I have not a question my research is
just directly there what I think over
there in the web so right now in the
copied world because things are moving
very fast and there are a lot of
scientists working together to try to
gather as much mass information about
the virus as possible then people
putting the in the preprint world so
people
so we have access to this knowledge
while it's being peer-review so this
doesn't mean that you don't do the peer
review it just means that you collect
the data you have the data available a
little bit faster today paper is
actually a paper already has gone
through the process of peer review so we
don't have to worry about some many
inconsistencies and some kind of like
bad quality of the reason so this is how
the paper looks like you can see here M
this is the title which is respiratory
viruses shedding in Excel breath and
efficacy of facemask so and these all
these people are the ones that work
together in order to bring this research
into one and make it available to all of
us so most of the like most of this work
was done was done in Hong Kong right
here in the south of China in two
different hospitals and institutions in
collaboration with institutions here in
the US so this is and one example of how
basically science is an international
collaboratory collaborative in
environments you can see that we don't
normally scientists don't care about
borders on boundaries in ethnicity or
location we normally if we need to work
together to make things happen
which way okay and why is this paper why
is this research important and I think
it's very important because if you see
all over the news for example here in
the Washington Post you have articles
saying like should we shoot Americans
wear masks
will they wear masks what is the purpose
of wearing masks in the in the UK the
Guardian was also saying it was also
posting the information that the
government's force is in forcing people
to wear masks here in New York City we
also have to wear masks in public spaces
by sampling warmer which is one of the
biggest in New York biggest US employees
employers is gonna make all their
employees wear masks
when they go to work some disease these
are like a lot of measures that are
taking different governments and
entities in order to prevent the virus
from spreading even if you see here
these are like news from from home where
they're saying that you have to wear
masks when you are in public spaces so
this is not only happening in the u.s.
it's all over the world but to make
these decisions for politicians and
public health specialists to make this
decision they have to have data that
supports in the policy otherwise it can
get into a very nasty territory or
forcing the enforcement people to do
something that is not actually worth it
so become so that's why we need papers
like these and science my piece in order
to drive or many public health and um
policies well so to introduce you to the
research I'm gonna first talk about four
key terms that are necessary to know in
order to understand the research the
method the methodology and the results
that you get and the first one int
respiratory viruses so I think now we
are we are all well well aware there are
respiratory viruses many of them the
ones are gonna a study here are the ones
that cause acute respiratory illness AR
eyes
so these are basically the one that
cause the common cold during the winter
that we all get at one point alone of
another so here we're gonna introduce
three different viruses the first one is
sort of like a classic influence of
Paris which is the one that causes the
flu we all get most of our games get a
flu shot at the beginning of the winter
in order to prevent these fires to to
infect us and make us sick the other one
that is the most common a respiratory
virus out there is this Rhino virus so
whenever you have the common cold and
unlike a runny nose
you have Rhino virus this is a classic
one is not that the
in the dangerous but it comes in all
different forms and we have the third
one that we are all very much familiar
now with the coronaviruses so this is
the one this is a kind of virus and now
it's affecting us during the pandemic a
outbreak so you can see here these are
pictures of the three different kind of
viruses and these are picture taken by
electron micrograph so basically you
have a super microscope that allows you
to see these very very very tiny
particles and as a side note I have to
say that most if not all of these
pictures come for taking around in the
70s by an by a technique that was
developed by a scientist called June and
Maeda so you know Maeda was basically de
pioneer in virals imaging so she was
born in 1964 and I mean sorry she in
1954 was the first one to identify human
coronaviruses so this is the first
picture that she took and was able to
see a corona virus so you can see
clearly these virus here that has this
crown around like I don't know and and
thanks to her we know that these virus
actually exists in the first place
and it's funny because when she sent her
paper to be peer review the reviewer
said that this was actually just
influenza virus with bad resolution that
she messed up with the technique and
then she had to basically further prove
and validate that this was another type
of virus it was not the influence of
ours so she was born in in Glasgow in
Scotland and actually left school when
she was 16 and started working in a
laboratory as a laboratory technician
and since then she basically develop all
these techniques then she moved to
Canada to get her PhD and then came back
to the US a story tool to England to
work in the world I don't remember where
right now and then when she did retire
around these in this 80s I think she
retired
became a yoga teacher and she actually
doing the HIV pandemic outbreak in the
United she came back to the lab to help
people to teach them her techniques in
order to visualize her so she was very
determined to understand how viruses
look like so mix okay so we have the
first aim the first key turned cover I
just want to clarify that right now the
pandemic is caused by these corona virus
name stars co2 and these corrupt did
that's the name of the virus and the
disease that causes is copied 19 so you
get copy 19 where you have the virus and
the virus is name is SARS cough - just
to clarify because it's it's kind of
messy the other thing that I want to
introduce you is what is the commonality
of all these viruses so all these
viruses besides that they don't cause
any respiratory illness they are also
all RNA viruses so what does that mean
it just means that they have RNA and
genetic information so I want to
introduce you to a turn up term like a
dogma that we have in molecular biology
called central dogma of molecular
biology who was a term by Francis Crick
in the 50s so basically is explaining
how the genetic information flows in in
biological systems so as you probably
all know we store our genetic
information in as DNA which is this a
poly polymer made of nucleotides in the
needs normally in our cells inside the
nuclei and it comes in a double-stranded
way so you can see it's obviously
double-stranded DNA and all whenever
they are talking about DNA you see these
pictures and DNA then send this
information only to RNA and RNA is like
a similar version of DNA but it has a
different chemical properties
it's also a polymer of nucleotides but
most commonly you find in a single
strand you can also see double cell but
single strand in and it makes a lot of
it has a lot of different functions in
them in the cell but some of the
function is also to make protein so this
is how information flows from DNA into
RNA into protein so the DNA and RNA
process is called transcription and the
RNA into protein is called translation
also we know that we know and it has to
happen then DNA can replicate itself by
a process called DNA replication so it's
maintain itself in the future so you can
divide yourselves and make more DNA and
just generally your progeny basically so
this is a process done by an specific
enzyme called DNA polymerase we're gonna
talk about her later or eat later I call
inside it because in Spanish she learned
see mice they're always here meaning for
me so irony irony can also replicate
itself I maintain something time by a
process called RNA replication and also
we will now know the irony can be go
back to DNA by a process called reverse
transcription which is done by another
enzyme called reverse transcriptase so
this is basically the the framework so I
can explain to you an answer this
question how do we detect viruses so
this is also all over the news it's very
good that we go through these because I
don't know I wake up every morning and I
see some headlines saying that we need
to test this test then what does it mean
we need to detect the virus and for that
we use a technique called rt-pcr so
rt-pcr stands for reverse transcriptase
polymerase chain reaction okay so that a
lot of blah no it doesn't mean anything
really so I'm going to explain to you
what it actually does and why I mean why
do we use it to detect the viruses so
when you have in Kiruna variants
somewhere what you do is just collect
the sample like when you
your test you get out like a nasal swab
or like a throat swab you connect the
sample and then you need to extract the
the genetic information is inside the
carnival's so that's an RNA molecule so
in order to do that you need to first
break the violins basically remove the
crown that we has that is protein and
lipids and release their RNA so we can
get the early how do we do that we do it
with soap so whenever you want to just
remove all the crown and get the RNA you
apply soap and then it's gonna be sold
dissolve it so that's why it's important
that you wash your hands in order to
kill the virus because so so actually
kills the viral Alif the RNA in exposed
and the irony it doesn't do anything it
dies very quickly so this I renamed
we're gonna put it inside a tube in the
lab so here you have the earning
molecules and the first step that we
need to do is gonna be getting this
enzyme that I talked to you before the
reverse transcriptase to work so what
does it do it's gonna transfer RNA into
DNA so we put the enzyme in here and
then we wait for a little bit and all
these RNA molecules are gonna become DNA
I reverse transcription I show you
before then this DNA we're gonna put it
in another tube here and we're gonna add
the second enzyme that we talked about
which is the DNA polymerase so basically
this first part is these reverse
transcriptase so you basically do put
the enzyme and transfer RNA into DNA and
we're gonna do the second part which is
the polymerase it's gonna go inside it
to and it's gonna you basically waiting
for a little bit like an hour you let it
like like sit there and put a little bit
of heat is like cooking basically and
these and someone's gonna do it's gonna
replicate the pieces of DNA all the time
so this allows us that by example in
this case to have two viruses and we
extract one molecule of RNA we're able
to have many
of DNA and this will give give us enough
resolution to see the DNA we are on ice
how do we do that this is like a more
complicated process but to simplify you
put the DNA inside a gel and this gel is
gonna have a green fluorescent molecule
and whenever the DNA interacts with the
green fluorescent molecule it's gonna
fluoresce a lot and you're gonna see so
whenever you have example that was
positive and you see the gel you're
gonna see a green March that he says
it's positive if your sample didn't have
any carnival's or any violence at all
you're not gonna see anything so that
basically the RT PCR test of we all need
to take in order to detect the presence
of the virus
I hope this was clear so here we're
gonna introduce you to we're gonna ask
you to answer this poll so the question
is sir scope 2 is an RNA virus in order
to detect it humans in in humans we use
rt-pcr 2 so the first option is to turn
virus in RNA into protein to see if the
viruses there is to turn RNA into DNA to
see the virus expression and two other
ways to measure RNA directly from the
virus sample so I I'm very happy that
most people are answering correctly at
least not more than 90 percent of the
people so people are following this is
great ok so I'm gonna leave the poll if
I move the poll it's fine Genie here
yeah I can it seems like I'll end the
poll and I'll show everybody yeah most
of you got it right yeah awesome
I hope everybody understand the first e
RNA inside the virus we have to put it
into DNA this is critical because a
first our names are very volatile
molecules so it guys very quickly DNA
can stay there for longer so we can
manipulate easy that's why you can
extract DNA for like mummies and stuff
like that no and then DNA you can
amplify the DNA to be a lot more so you
can see the signal more easily than just
having one or two viral samples so this
is great I'm okay so should I close it
yeah okay so I'm gonna then introduce
you to the third important a key term is
shedding a person from itself breath so
whenever I'm exciting breath like okay
it's not uncommon I'm just exhaling or
talking like that you can throw away two
kind of particles one is these
respiratory droplets which are dfi like
beat drop droplets of water
liquin which are larger than five
micrometers and if you see here this
picture taking a very fast in in frames
per second you can see that in normally
when you sneeze assume you cough and
when you talk you throw these big
particles and they fall very rapidly
into surface because they are kidding
and that's why you have to kind of clean
surfaces because people are like sending
these these particles all over and you
also have these older a small fine
aerosol particles and these are smaller
than five micrometers and when you
exhale they can linger in the air for a
very long time no they don't fall off so
you you have you have these kind two
different kind of particles going around
so these pictures are taken by people in
the love of Lydia Volvo driver in at MIT
and she is doing an amazing we're trying
to study the dynamics of this process so
I recommend to take a look at her
research and okay and the first key term
is basically
surgical face mask so in this study they
are not gonna use the specific
n95 face mask that everybody's talking
about that we need because those we
already know they prevent explaining of
everything that comes out of your mouth
so you don't see any virus coming out
we're gonna talk about these classic
surgical masks are much cheaper easily
available not right now because we don't
have production but these are the ones
are basically most of the people are
using on the streets and they have aim
so they are disposable and we want to
know whether they prevent the spreading
of viruses okay so great I went through
all the introductions we already know
what our spirit or a viruses are but
isn't rt-pcr technique what are their
respiratory droplets and aerosol and
also what are the surgical face masks so
now we're gonna go into the research so
the aim of this research was basically
to
I'm divided in two different parts one
is to investigate the importance of the
respiratory droplets and aerosol on
transmission of viruses so the first
question is whether when I'm exhaling
breath and I have these two kind of
particles
do they have fires that's it no the
second one is see whether they think
efficiency of the third surgical face
map will prevent these variants
transmission so if I'm if I have them
ask on and I Excel first do I spread the
virus basically those are the two
questions okay so I'm I know that rocky
do you and the pre-order percentages
we've been covering a lot about these
stay on scientific and reasoning so when
you start in preparing and thinking
about your experiment and how to address
your hypothesis and to prove it you have
different forms of aim basically go
through a basically different forms of
how to construct your research and in
this case this research specifically
it's a it's going through under
experimental evaluations obviously
they're gonna do experiments and then
gonna evaluate and document what they
observe in the different cases and also
they're gonna have they are gonna be
control experiments because you you
collect all the sample on the control
and control environment that you
basically control every other variable
that is available and you're only
looking into one variable on itself so
the experimental design looks like this
first in Hong Kong in the hospital they
scream people who have these AR eye
symptoms symptoms so they were having
the common cold
so they screen more than 3,000
individuals and then they ask these
individuals whether they wanted to
participate in this research so once you
say yes I want to participate they they
basically a screen deeply and make sure
they have the specific viruses that they
are studying and the influencer reverse
corner virus
out of all these people scream they
selected only 246 individuals so all of
these 256 individuals are gonna go
through the process of exhaled breath
collection so they're gonna ask them to
excel and the scientists are gonna
collect their breath sample divided into
these two different particles the
droplets on the aerosols and analyze
them so half of these individuals I'm
gonna do this by not wearing a face mask
and the other half aren't gonna do it
with the face mask and then we're gonna
do the rt-pcr on these samples and see
whether they you can find burials in
there exhale breath or you cannot find
ours this is a simple as it goes so
these are the results here I'm gonna
show you first the resolve for influenza
virus so with me I want you to see that
in the y-axis here we have this they are
measuring the various copies per sample
so how much are in a barrel I can find
on each sample through my rt-pcr and
here in the x-axis you have all the
conditions so the first two ones aren't
gonna be or controls so the first one is
not nasal swab so when they put a swab
stick inside your nose they collect the
sample and then you're gonna analyze it
for virus and you're gonna see that most
of the people or most of the people had
a lot of influence of variants in these
in their noses and they same with this
throat swabs so they put this off stick
inside there so very very deeply they
collected and they wanna see whether
they can find the virus so most of the
people have virus inside them so then
the question is whether you can find the
virus and Excel breath so first for the
big droplets when they peep when people
are not wearing masks you can still find
droplets that have virus inside and so
you here see this is a point and you see
here it you can still find a like more
than more than 100
a thousand viral copies in that sample
so that's a lot comparing to the people
that are wearing masks for the big
droplets you can see that you barely
only find one individual that it was
able to spread the virus through the
mask
so this is like it looks pretty good so
in the case of this small also that can
maybe go through the mask they are able
to collect for people without the mask
also virus is being shed in this form of
Arizona and with the mask they can find
a lot of people who are able to shed the
virus using the mask so this means that
for influenza it might not be such a
useful thing to use these faceless so in
the case of Rhino virus we're gonna see
here the same table basically in the
y-axis you are measuring the viral in
samples and in the X Isis the only
conditions so here in our control we
have the nice on the throw swab that
have a lot of virus you can see here it
find the Rhino virus they want to get to
you like they live runny nose so most of
them are things in your nose
and you can see that you can find a lot
of virus in your nose complain to your
throat that's a sign no and when they
analyze the beat drop lengths people who
are not wearing the mask they are able
to share virus inside these two big
droplets without a problem it's not the
same amount but it's enough to detect it
and wearing the mask you can still find
a lot of these droplets with virus okay
in the case of the a small aerosol
particles this is even more dire so you
can see here that we don't without them
without with the mask you don't have
much of a difference in the amount of
viral particles you find in the aerosols
and in the aerosols so doesn't this
means that for Rhino virus wearing a
mask is actually not that useful to
prevent the shedding of virus so we're
gonna go now to see the results for the
corona virus which is or like most
important virus now
we all care about him so in the case of
coronavirus again we have the same table
in the same graph here when they measure
various copy for sampling the y axis and
the x axis the different conditions they
control
so nice on and throw swap they find a
lot of virus there in so these people
are infected so when they are using when
they are not using face masks and they
analyze the big droplets Excel from this
in these individuals you can see that
they are still able to find individuals
who are shedding the virus through the
PA through the press but with the masks
they are not able to find any
environment sample at all
this is good news in the case of a small
Arizona they also find that people
without mask and shape the virus in this
more aerosols but when you put the mask
on this goes to zero again so this is
pretty good news I will say this is my
opinion so here are basically the
numbers so this is a table how it looks
like how they present it in the paper
so if here the first condition you see
the an analysis of the big droplet and
the second condition the analysis of the
small aerosol particles so here you can
see the the rows are analyzed analyzing
carnival's influence servers and Rhyno
balance so aim as I said be before for
the corona bar I'm gonna go through de
the corona balance only because that's
the most important now aim more deeply
so if you see here for the big droplets
you can out of the in 10 people who
didn't wear the mask they detected the
three of them were able to shed the
virus on these teeth droplets and then
when they put the fake when when people
have face masks none of them were able
to share the virus with these big
droplets this is meaningful it means a
wearing this mask and if you're infected
with the virus you will
these droplets to come out with variants
all over so if you breed you will not
share these big droplets into the
surface and then people who touches
those surface will not get viral
particles in their hands in the case of
a more small Arizona we also see a lot
of a fricassee of the mask so people
could not don't wear the mask if I'm the
four out of ten people 40% were able to
shed the virus through these aerosol
particles so this means that every time
you breathe you have 40% chances of this
like spreading the virus to somebody and
using the face mask it goes to zero so
this is major again in the case of the
other two viruses they were analyzing
for influenza virus the masks were very
effective only for to prevent the spread
of the virus inside the big droplets
complain to the aerosol particles very
still goes out and in them run around
hissing not too it looks like it doesn't
make any difference so these are pretty
good new for the situation that we are
in right now
okay so with this and I'm gonna
basically wrap it up so why was the aim
of this research so we said it is too
important and questions so one it's
basically the potential transmission of
viruses through these respiratory
droplets and the aerosols and we can see
that aerosol transmission is possible
for all three viruses that we they
studied here for influenza random errors
and corona virus and also the second
question then it's whether surgical face
masks prevent the spreading of the virus
through the exhale breath so the answer
here is not yes it's not it's not like
yes or not it's basically it depends on
what kind of virus you are exposed to
and what kind of particle you are
measuring so they were able to deduce a
wearing first method actually if you
trip reduces the emission of the corona
balance through both respiratory
droplets and the aerosols in the case of
influenza it was more divided because
the droplets maybe are not been
containing the virus but you think I
still spread the virus who are so
particles even wearing the face mask and
in the case of Rhino virus it seems that
it's not very useful so I want to exit
the presentation and show you basically
add video illustrating this and so this
is a video of somebody who's gonna be
either not wearing a face back and then
wearing a face man
I mean he's this person is gonna be
talking and what we're gonna see is
basically the aerosol particles that are
being spread into the up the air around
him so these are so particles are gonna
basically light up in green fluorescent
green
No
looks like now I'm recording straight
healthy these persons talking you see
all these all these particles coming out
green stay healthy you see here know all
of that is just speak this far out is
enough now he's wearing a mask okay
stay healthy stay healthy you see a few
particles lighting that but they are not
that many no should I put it again I
think it was pretty good and we can
share the link to this if you'd like so
that people can watch it on their own
perfect yeah so okay so basically this
is all all this research is done in
individuals in in Excel breath so this
is not people who are sneezing coughing
or just like I don't know reading very
lovely this is a regular breath so you
can see here this is a picture of
somebody just is missing and this means
and all these aerosol particles can
spread for more than seven to eight
meters away from you again so this is
even with the social distancing
measurements that we have right now
seven to eight meters it's a lot we have
now two meters six feets that that means
that you can be spreading virus all over
the plate is your sneezing okay that
just to put it into perspective if
you're sick stay home because there is
no way that you can socially distances
with these distance in any unless you
live like a faraway land